en los dos últimos vídeos estuvimos
platicando acerca del interés compuesto
sin embargo fue en el último vídeo en
donde apareció este número mágico
llamado el y esencialmente no era otra
cosa sino el límite cuando en entidad
infinito la expresión que tenemos aquí
me tomé la libertad de calcular en excel
algunos valores algunos valores para n
para que se den cuenta lo rápido que
converge ahí se dan cuenta lo único que
hice fue tomar valores distintos para n
y poner esta fórmula la voy a poner aquí
para que se den cuenta que es lo que
hice puse esta fórmula 1 más 1 entre en
elevado a la n aquí es uno más 1 entre
el número que está a la izquierda y todo
esto elevado al número que está a la
izquierda y lo único que hice fue variar
n duplicando lo en cada celda que esté
abajo es decir abajo se encuentra el
doble del número que está arriba y se
dan cuenta muy rápidamente convergen
convergen 2.718 3 y también estuve
buscando en google y en google encontré
el valor de google tiene una calculadora
y esta calculadora me dice el valor
exacto de que es 2.7 1828 183 y más
dígitos recuerden que es un número
irracional y por lo tanto es un número
que tiene decimales infinitos y en el
vídeo pasado yo te mencionaba que este
número es un número especial o un número
mágico al igual que pio al igual que el
número de fibonacci y yo digo que es un
número mágico y a mí me encanta hablar
de ellos porque aparecen en muchas
aplicaciones de la matemática aparecen
también en muchas situaciones de la
naturaleza y en este en los siguientes
vídeos voy a hablar acerca de este tipo
de números sobre todo en el caso del
número de hoy leer y espero que
encuentras una motivación para que si
estás de humor encuentres un nuevo
oculto o una nueva forma de pensar
acerca de estos números pero bueno voy a
regresar este vídeo para aprender
interés compuesto porque si no no vamos
a poder financiar nuestro nuevo culto
nuestra nueva ideología entonces voy a
borrar la pantalla y
vamos a hablar acerca de la importancia
del número de hoy leer en el interés
compuesto o bueno tal vez al final
existe alguna persona que nos financie
en nuestro culto como los famosos
usureros pero bueno vamos a cambiar de
tema
regresemos al interés compuesto y voy a
hablar acerca de la tasa de interés
entonces ese va a ser mi tasa de interés
o mejor aún lo voy a poner aérea en
decimal entonces voy a borrar este el
signo de porcentaje y no voy a llamar
como porcentaje y lo voy a llamar como
decimal es decir si lo que sigamos en
porcentaje tenemos que multiplicar 10
veces r y eso sería nuestro porcentaje
entonces estamos hablando de nuestra
tasa de interés por ejemplo si yo
quisiera en lugar de tener el 100 por
ciento con el que trabajábamos tener el
25 por ciento de nuestra tasa de interés
pues sería punto 25 si fuera decimal y
25 por ciento
aquí está 25 por ciento sería nuestra
tasa de interés y bueno vamos a regresar
al caso general o al caso abstracto
acerca de lo que vamos a pagar después
de un cierto tiempo tendríamos que era
el capital o el préstamo inicial y a
esto lo multiplicamos por uno más y en
lugar de poner el 100% ahora voy a
hablar de la tasa de interés que va a
ser r
r los dividimos entre n que n era la
cantidad de periodos en los cuales se
iba a dividir mi tiempo y todo esto lo
elevamos a la n y vamos a jugar dando el
de valores ap
r vamos a suponer esta vez que revele el
10% tenemos una tasa de interés del 10%
n es igual a 2 es decir tenemos una tasa
de interés cada seis meses semestral
recuerden que dividimos al año en dos
periodos es decir en cada seis meses
vamos a suponer que son 50 pesos
entonces que vamos a obtener si nosotros
calculamos lo que vamos a pagar en los
primeros en los primeros seis meses esto
nos quedaría de la siguiente manera
sería vamos a ponerlo aquí esto en los
primeros seis meses
y obtener a 50 los 50 pesos que te
presencialmente el capital más r entre n
es decir el 10% dividido entre 2 vamos a
ponerlo el 10% dividido entre 2 10%
dividido entre 2 ya esto hay que
multiplicarlo por porque hay que
multiplicarlo por la cantidad de dinero
que te presencialmente por 50 es decir
es la ganancia o mi retribución por
haberte prestado el dinero los primeros
seis meses ahora bien esto es lo mismo
que 50 vamos a factorizar el 50-50 que
multiplica a uno más el 10% entre dos
bueno eso es lo que pasaría en los
primeros seis meses qué va a pasar si tú
te tratas en pagarme no 6 meses sino un
año entonces hay que tener esta cantidad
esta cantidad le voy a llamar x y
entonces tú vas a pagar esta cantidad
más de nuevo mi tasa de interés entre la
cantidad de periodos es decir x más el
10% entre 2 que multiplica a x
o dicho de otra manera esto es x factor'
izado que multiplica a 1 más el 10 entre
2 y ahora si si sustituimos a x me va a
quedar 50 que multiplica a 1 + 10 %
entre 2 que multiplica a su vez a 1 +
10% entre 2 y bueno todo esto a dónde me
lleva esto me está llevando ahora voy en
sentido contrario a tener 50 que era el
capital inicial que multiplica a uno más
y ahora si en lugar de 10% voy a poner
punto 1 entre 2 todo esto elevado al
cuadrado es decir la fórmula que tenemos
aquí arriba y tú lo puedes variar tú
puedes cambiarle cualquier otro valor a
p
y vas a ir viendo que si tú lo haces
como experimento vas a llegar de nuevo a
esta fórmula que tenemos aquí arriba es
decir esta fórmula funciona siempre que
quieras calcular el interés compuesto y
para eso necesitas una tasa de interés
una cantidad de períodos en los cuales
vas a dividir tu tiempo y un capital o
una cantidad inicial o un préstamo
inicial como lo quieras ver pero ahora
sí
a ver qué es lo que pasa cuando n tiende
a infinito es decir vamos a hablar del
caso continuo por lo tanto quiero ver
qué es lo que va a pasar con el pago
final el pago final que está dado ya no
tenemos ya tenemos una fórmula por p que
multiplica a 1 más r entre en todo esto
elevado a la n ok ahora yo puse uno más
r entre en elevado a la n con otro color
porque primero me voy a fijar en ello yo
lo que quiero es que n tiende a infinito
primero me voy a fijar en rn no no no
mejor no primero me voy a fijar en toda
la expresión en uno más r entre en
elevado a la n yo lo que quiero es el
límite cuando n tiende a infinito es
decir cuando n se hace cada vez más
grande de la expresión uno más r entre n
todo esto elevado a la n yo lo que
quiero saber es a cuánto equivale este
límite y para obtener el valor de este
límite voy a hacer este cambio de
variable voy a decir que uno entre x es
igual ayer entre n o dicho de otra
manera aquí si despejó a n me va a
quedar que n es igual a x por r
ahora bien fíjense en estas dos
expresiones que pasan cuando n tiende a
infinito bueno si n tiende a infinito
entonces no queda de otra más que x
tiende a infinito porque eres una
constante eres un valor que yo le estoy
dando desde un inicio entonces si n
tiende a infinito esto implica que x
tiende a infinito ojo esto lo voy a
utilizar justo ahorita porque yo lo que
quiero escrito de otra manera es el
límite cuando n tiende a infinito y
cuando x también tiende a infinito de
qué expresión de uno más r entre n pero
era entre d es uno entre x es uno más
uno entre x elevado a la n pero en ella
despejamos en valores o en términos de x
es lo mismo que x por r aquí lo único
que hice fue cambiar este límite que
dependía de n a este límite que depende
de x porque me va a ser más fácil
resolverlo con x es decir cuando x
tiende a infinito y ahora sí aquí viene
el truco de este vídeo por las leyes de
los exponentes esto es lo mismo que el
límite cuando extiende infinito
+ 1 / x elevado a la equis todo esto
elevado a la r recuerden que cuando
tenemos una cantidad elevada a una
potencia elevada una potencia las
potencias se multiplican y en este
momento voy a utilizar una propiedad de
los límites porque cuando yo tengo el
límite cuando x tiende a infinito de uno
más uno entre x todo esto elevado a la x
yo puedo sacar la potencia al final es
decir la potencia r porque al final r no
depende de x por lo tanto el límite
puede entrar en el paréntesis de la
potencia r y que creen aquí ya nos dimos
cuenta que esto es lo mismo que elevado
a la r porque recuerden que la
definición que teníamos del número de
oler era el límite cuando existiendo
infinito de uno más uno entre x elevado
a la equis por lo tanto si sustituimos
este límite por y me va a quedar elevado
al aire y en el caso que veíamos
anteriormente he elevado a la punto uno
cuando r valía el 10 por ciento de la
tasa de interés y aquí me faltaba una p
aquí le voy a poner es más aquí se va a
confundir para que la recuerden la voy a
poner de color azul esta p me venía bien
aquí también está viene aquí también
recuerden que solamente es un factor de
escala por lo tanto puedo sacar la p es
una constante pp y ya la tenemos aquí y
bueno con esta nueva fórmula encontramos
el pago final que nosotros obtenemos en
el caso continuo y como ya estamos
apresurados de tiempo te cuento que en
el siguiente vídeo vamos a ver qué es lo
que pasa cuando tenemos múltiples años
así que no te pierdas el siguiente vídeo